oh my god we're gonna wax today so many
men get their arms wax due to the fact
that they want armed definition if
they're working out and also it makes
them look much nicer during the
summertime short sleeves tank tops it's
just a good look sometimes I do feel
self-conscious if I'm wearing a t-shirt
and all of my hair it's exposed I have
very fine blond hair and so I'm curious
how subtle or not subtle the difference
would be Rock Paper Scissors shoot
you're gonna first bunny I was a little
warmer than I thought it'd be but can I
help you is there anything I can do okay
oh she's going it just keeps rolling I'm
so much help and they said I didn't have
any hair and they said my hair was
invisible and blonde and it wouldn't be
a thing but there it is world you know
his hand yeah that one I'm sweating now
I don't know maybe I'll get more respect
to the gym now but the other hairless
gym rats I don't know I feel really good
I'm kind of impressed right now cuz I
thought my hair was so blond and thin
it'd be a really subtle difference but
there's definitely some more muscle
definition all right Mike your turn I'm
terrified we're gonna have to go all the
way up your arm we can't just leave it
at the fork clean it all the way no
we're doing just the forearms now we'll
take it slow because well you know in
small portions cuz your hair girl oh my
god Wow oh ah there's so much more hair
on my arm oh God Oh need me to hold him
down no for all the viewers at home
this was my entire arm versus half of
one of Mike's arms ah oh my god my hand
looks like an elephant's penis oh I'm
exhausted I kind of liked it but based
on the amount of hair you see on these
sheets you could have probably guessed
that maybe before we started what a
transformative experience I'm a lot more
emotionally attached to this arm having
this arm wax really made me appreciate
actually having hair on my arm and like
this feels really really comfortable for
me and even though some people might
find it weird to have a hairy arm
I actually prefer it if you elect to do
this kudos to you someone you're in a
committed relationship with asks you to
wax your arm your reaction is
thank you for dating me it's been fun